[Música]
[Aplausos]
a cuando se vosotros os ha ocurrido en
la vida alguna vez alguna crisis o algún
tipo de indecisión de que es que hago
ahora
a cuántos de vosotros
suena
en mito que no es verdad que en chino
crisis es peligro y oportunidad os suena
esto si lo dicen que sea y no es verdad
sea toda una industria de coaching
basado sobre esto que no es verdad
imagínate no es así
el chino crisis significa peligro sí y
punto crucial punto de decisión
dt escisión punto de cambio punto de
decisión de stop and start es lo que
significa crisis entonces a conoce
vosotros os gustaría hoy saber cómo
aprovechar esas crisis que tenemos para
dar el salto en tu vida qué quieres
hacer y estar más en paz pues
bienvenidos estáis un lugar correcto no
es alcohólicas anónimos
soy que rima clean soy inglés y no es mi
culpa
soy causa y formador y speaker y vivo en
madrid y hace 21 años en barcelona y
bueno ahora esto es mi historia
lo que vamos a hacer es mirar hoy lo que
vamos a transmitir son
en las cinco etapas de la vida y cada
una de esas etapas infancia adolescencia
acuerdo social de explicar algo poco más
ahora auto creación y sabiduría cada
etapa suele estar preferida por una
crisis de algún tipo
algunos de vosotros estáis más
familiarizados con la crisis de mediana
edad
habéis escuchado hablar de ello
no sé si preparamos vamos a hablar un
poco más de ello
pero primero antes de ir ahí lo que me
gustaría hacer es hacer un juego con
vosotros en vuestras bolsas tenéis un
metro
vale
porque hemos sacada del metro
si podéis
muy bien
[Aplausos]
cuando lo tenéis mira de 0
a la edad que tienes hoy y nadie lo va a
haber
puede ser honesto contigo mismo al menos
vale
mira la edad que tienes hoy
grábalo miralo
yo tengo 54 ok mil 854 miro de 0 a 54 y
miro guau gracias por mi vida
gracias por todo eso ok míralo y piensa
que hay que has puesto en esta vida
hasta ahora cuánto hay aquí qué bueno
qué fantástico difícil momentos de
crucial de crisis aunque lo que fuera
das gracias ahora mismo a esto vale 10
segundos mientras lo pongo en el
bolsillo guárdalo no hagas nada solo
míralo aunque hay muy importante para
esta charla
y está bien
bien en esta vida que has puesto y hoy
también puedes haber puesto 1 de 4
actitudes a tu vida
la primera que puedes tener ahora aunque
lo dudo porque habéis pagado por entrar
lo dudo es la actitud del escéptico
el acto de vivir tiene que ser muy bueno
para convencerme a mí
he oído mucho usted sí hay muchas cosas
que es posible
ante esta charla y la vida la segunda es
la actitud china que es ni fú ni fá
qué es
es otra vez me han traído aquí me han
obligado a venir desde barcelona desde
que voy a ver menos mal que café porque
si no no vengo
es una actitud posible hacia la vida
también hay otra actitud que es muy
inglesa es interesting
no sé si cuando hablan inglés aquí
los que hablan inglés saben que si un
inglés te dice que algo es interesting
no lo es
lo siento es intel y es creencia
intelectual y es como decir entre estén
pero más interesante mi yate como en el
avión de vuelta vale entonces es
interesante es posible pero bueno y la
actitud que queremos en esta charla con
dos ponentes que tenemos aquí hoy y con
tu vida para tener esta vida realmente
que vale la alegría en esta vida es la
actitud de 100% por y eso está en mi
hija pequeña a jona makers mañana otra
de china hay una media tiene ocho años y
cuando quiere algo dice es que te haría
lo quiero
vamos a hacerlo todo y lo quiero 123 no
quiero otra vez
otra vez esto
genial bueno asi asi os queremos totes
acuerdo social vamos a ir a en una
historia que demuestra todo lo que son
las etapas de la vida y la crisis y cómo
funciona de acuerdo el acuerdo social
qué es
el acuerdo social es esta parte de tu
vida donde crees que has llegado
porque en esta época que suele estar
después de luís gente hay gente que
prolonga la adolescencia de más que
otros
yo era uno de ellos
o soy no lo sé
que el acuerdo social es cuando te
entregan el libro de los tengo que es
tengo que tener una casa tengo que tener
un trabajo tengo que tener una mujer un
marido tengo que tener hijos endurecer
un coche vale si lo tenemos y cuando el
libro está lleno
está lleno qué pasa
es cuando en el hombre suele ser no es
para todos el hombre suele hacerse la
pregunta y para qué hago todo esto
y muchas veces la mujer se pregunta
y para mí que hay después antes es
interesante cuando es donde vamos a
estar es el acuerdo social como yo entré
en acuerdo social
está bien no queréis escuchar
he visto más entusiasmo en el funeral de
mi abuela en el islam de enero
sí
genial mira entonces os voy a explicar
una cosa
mi infancia mi adolescencia fueron
marcados mucho por mi padre
voy a ir acuerdo social bueno mi padre
tenía dos mensajes básicas en la vida
uno es notifíquese nadie
y otro era el trabajo es una palabrota
porque en inglés trabajo es work tiene
cuatro letras y todas las palabrotas de
inglés tienen cuatro letras
su idea de trabajo de xabi tienes que
trabajar lo menos posible por más dinero
posible
pero a la vez tiene que estudiar era un
poco confuso yo crecí con la idea que yo
era vago
bastante vago que no tenía mucho que dar
al mundo y que lo que quiere hacer es
evitar trabajar
entonces me fui a la universidad para
evitar trabajo hice un máster para
evitar trabajar y después de esto a la
edad de 23 años no cabía más doctorados
en el currículum currículum entonces
decidí que necesitaba dinero pero no
quería trabajar entonces lo que hice fue
buscar un trabajo quien no era un
trabajo que quedaba dinero esto tiene
que convertir en profesor de universidad
entonces vamos a ver me fui a
montpellier en francia trabajé ahí ya
que habéis trabajando en el roma pero no
quería trabajar todavía quería prolongar
la adolescencia en mi etapa y que paso
pues tiene luna está de broma conocí a
una chica verdad
me enamoré de ella meta liana estaba
donde viví china la paralizó por primera
vez en italia y entonces quería
prolongar esta bohemia aunque la
relación no iba muy bien pero yo quería
prolongar la entonces fui a la
universidad en junio 91 y les dije
volvió a renovar y mi contrato
habéis entendido ellos dijeron no
volvía a casa y dijo a bera bera non al
novato y el contrato y ella dijo terry
no me la única cosa que termina hasta
textualmente fue así es la mejor forma
de aje para la relación que he conocido
en mi vida
jaja
entonces ahí estoy en italia sin dinero
sin regata sin trabajo sin futuro 26
años
crisis total mi plan de vida hecha
trizas no tenía plan estaba en crisis
total
entonces cogí un mapa
de esos mapas que antes existían
lo puse en el suelo cogí un alfiler dije
donde cae el alfiler voy yo como dice el
kart soy un hombre del mundo soy el
hombre es bueno con todo
ya
moscú
entonces digo vale pues 9 barcelona
bueno
entonces en barcelona qué pasa
en barcelona yo fui a londres durante
verano gana dinero enseñando inglés a
catalanes españoles italianos
no entendieron mucho pero bueno y
entonces bastantes días juntos bueno
llegué a barcelona en 191 antes
olimpíadas la merced tenía dinero yo
para cuatro meses fácil en un mes que
hasta todo me echaron del hostal parís
en la rambla me echaron porque no podría
pagar y acabé durmiendo en la plaza
urquinaona 22 y 26 años sin cuarto con
muchas carreras pero sin trabajo sin
futuro sin plan sin nada
hoy tenía hambre básicamente vamos en
maslow vamos sabes más low pirámide más
abajo wi fi y wi fi no existía en ese
momento entonces la grafía falta comer
entonces
[Música]
claro
qué puedo hacer si cantar más o menos
baje las ramblas
y empecé durante café ópera delante de
confío pero empecé a pensar
típico típico no voy a prolongar la
agonía empecé a cantar antes dos
canciones del libro de la selva
y ganes mil pesetas
no sólo esto es curioso porque muchas
veces se asocia a acuerdo social con
trabajar un banco o un trabajo normal y
luego complementar nos dice que quiere
ser estrella de rock
yo este momento encontré mi lugar
de golpe el mundo el cambio hice ese
paso cante y vi que había gente que
estaba disfrutando gente que estaba
feliz y yo también y gana dinero
empecé a pensar
puedo vivir así entonces fui a casa mi
ética de trabajo cambió totalmente me
puse a aprender la guitarra a aprender a
cantar más canciones dentro de dos
semanas estaban en tres grupos y los
grupos de teatro ya era artista hice
tarjetas con mi nombre y no soy un actor
cantante
pero ya está yo era eso cambió
totalmente mi ética de trabajo y gracias
gracias gracias a veras
verán que todavía hoy soy amigo de ella
en facebook tiene tres hijos y está
feliz y gracias a ella gracias a mi
crisis gracias a esto pude avanzar
y estar donde estoy aquí y ahora debo
este momento estar aquí con vosotros a
esta crisis pase de la adolescencia a
microsocial y pensé feliz para siempre
entonces durante 15 años
trabajé como artista y
tenía completa expresión del teatro
pero es curioso la crisis funciona de
forma maravillosa
después de 2500 actuaciones de teatro
básicamente para adolescentes dentro de
europa que lo sepáis los adolescentes es
un público fantástico porque te dicen la
verdad
- canción de oh
el que faltaba esas cosas te dicen que
es fantástico porque son honestos el
público adulto en general es muy light
no aplauden y van a casa diciendo vaya
[ __ ] que esto
pero bueno es tan drástico y después de
2500 salí al escenario estuve de acuerdo
estuve en la escuela de fp de olot
salí y me di cuenta como michael
corleone en el padrino me di cuenta que
yo ya no estaba nervioso
yo ya no estaba nerviosa
si yo me despierto con la idea
o estoy no estoy nervioso
es un termómetro que vamos a hablar más
tarde
es un tema metro que que las cosas están
mal hay otra crisis que está
y ahora está cerca
es curioso en este mismo periodo
acabé separándome acá parece otra vez
durmiendo en mi coche
y acabé con otra crisis básicamente y
entonces es cuando decidí la experiencia
pasada de mi crisis anterior que me
había llegado a la verdad
decidí dejar todo deje mi compañía de
teatro dejé todo y me lancé al mundo de
formación y coaching donde hoy estoy
felizmente y expresamente instalado y
aquí estoy con vosotros entonces lo que
estoy diciendo es que cada vez que
tienes una crisis escucha te escucha esa
crisis estuve inconsciente diciéndote
hey
hora de cambiar
bienvenida la axis es bueno
mira
la última parte
qué es sabiduría yo no llegué a auto la
vida un amigo mío llegó dejó su trabajo
porque por enfermedad y encontró lo que
es la sabiduría realmente estaba feliz
estaba realmente en paz
emana la paz y esta semana el martes
este hecho murió
decidí ponerle a mi amigo ponerle aquí
con vosotros para animaros está al cien
por cien en esta vida
y mirar [ __ ] las cintas por favor
mirar tu edad miralo
y ahora coge en el punto de tu edad
ahora cógelo y rompe lo
cógelo en la mano varias manos arriba a
todos
dale un beso y le gracias a dios y
tíralo
porque ya no vuelve
ya no vuelve a esta parte a stops ha
parado
ahora vas a mirar la siguiente parte
mira resto de tu vida decide hasta qué
edad quieres vivir
míralo
y decide qué actitud tienes poner ahí
qué cosas que les ve por ahí que quieres
crear vive tus crisis vive todo por lo
que quieres vivir aquí por lo visualiza
lo visualiza lo y al final decide tú qué
película quieres ver con miras a
transmitir esto fue mi vida
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]